surprising cameos hidden song meetings
and a makeup tutorial did you catch all
these details in baz luhrman's HBO Elvis
biopic fans may have missed all the
hidden Star Trek references throughout
the film first in the beginning of the
movie at the international hotel in
Vegas there's an advertisement for the
Star Trek Experience on the sign out
front and there's at least one other
reference later in the film during the
Christmas special while Tom Parker and
the NBC Studio Executives walk the
hallways at NBC Studios there are
several Star Trek posters hanging up
that promote the show some might think
be small Star Trek details are merely a
coincidence but they are actually
purposely hidden in the film The King
was a huge fan of Star Trek of both the
cast and the show's storylines Celeste
Yarnell Star Trek actress and Elvis
on-screen co-star talked about how much
Elvis loved the show and that Elvis even
named one of his horses Star Trek
because of the king's love for the show
lorman wanted to include some small Star
Trek details that hardcore Elvis fans
would recognize as an homage to his
fandom one of Elvis's most famous films
is Blue Hawaii in the film Elvis plays
Chad a boy who was meant to take over
his family business but throws it away
in favor of working for his girlfriend
as a tour guide at the agency she owns
the film also starred the late Angela
Lansbury and included hits like Blue
Hawaii Aloha oi and most famously Can't
Help Falling in Love there's a whole
section of lerman's film that pays
tribute to Elvis's movie career but one
of the homages to Elvis's acting is a
small detail you might have missed
so you're wondering
tonight a bit over 35 minutes into Elvis
He and BB King go shopping for new
outfits at a store called lanskies while
in the store there's a shot of all the
shelves and other products in the store
aside from what the two musicians are
purchasing in this shot you can see a
row of shirts displayed behind Elvis and
one of the shirts is the iconic red
Hawaiian style shirt he wears in Blue
Hawaii it's a small detail and the shot
is fleeting but Die Hard Elvis fans can
keep their eyes peeled for this small
homage to one of Elvis's most famous
acting moments
one of the most action-packed sequences
of the film comes from the Viva Las
Vegas Montage where the audience sees
shots of real Elvis films reenactments
featuring Butler and moments with Elvis
and Priscilla or Elvis and his Memphis
Mafia as they were called there are
several panels going at once making it
the perfect place to slip in some
smaller details about the musician and
actor though many fans see this as a
moment where it's once again hard to
tell the difference between the real
Elvis and Butler's iteration there's one
panel where you can absolutely be sure
it's the real Elvis because of the other
actor making a cameo in the scene one of
the panels behind Butler's Elvis while
he's filming the surfing shots shows a
memorable scene from Elvis's film it
happened at the World's Fair the scene
involves Elvis asking a young child to
kick him in the shin no kidding I'll
tell you what if you kick me in the shin
real hard I'll give you a quote
go ahead play it ah the child actor is
actually Kurt Russell who's starred in
films like the hateful eight and
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2. the
Russell Cameo is also meaningful because
he eventually played Elvis and John
Carpenter's 1979 biopic Elvis the 2022
Kurt Russell moment is brief but bear
for those who pay close attention
Elvis experienced a lot of mental stress
throughout his career mostly because Tom
Parker kept him continually running with
no room to rest this type of exhaustion
is something many celebrities experience
but Elvis in particular was dealing with
the assassinations of John F Kennedy and
Martin Luther King Jr while watching
other celebrities murdered or attacked
just for their Fame Memphis is burning I
do fear his brother when you teach that
he is a lesser man because of his color
or his beliefs this took a huge toll on
him and inspired paranoia in Elvis that
helped Parker control his life one scene
that perfectly encapsulates this is when
Elvis is in the hospital for exhaustion
Parker is reading a newspaper with
Sharon Tate's murder blazed across the
cover this is used as a plot device to
spark a discussion about fear for the
lives of entertainers but for Butler
fans it can be seen as an homage to his
role as Tex one of Tate's killers in the
Quentin Tarantino film Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood it's a small detail that
only fans of Butler or the Tarantino
film would know but it's fun nonetheless
the relationship between Elvis and his
wife Priscilla is one of the film's
primary storylines the audience gets to
see their romance at every stage
starting with how they meet and bond
never met anyone like you
I hope not and ending with their divorce
and co-parenting style there's one scene
that's particularly heartbreaking
because of how clear it is to the
audience that they still love each other
but just can't work as a couple anymore
when they are talking together in the
car toward the end of the film it's a
heart-to-heart that only Priscilla could
help Elvis get through they both get out
of the car to leave and Elvis looks at
Priscilla and mouths
it's a tearful moment but it's one with
a deeper meaning than just the sentiment
Elvis famously saying Dolly Parton's I
will always love you to Priscilla when
the two were getting divorced his wife
told me that when they divorced that
when they were coming out of the
courthouse Elvis sang that song to her
and that just touched me so deep but
even more than this Elvis wanted to
professionally record Parton's song and
she wanted that as well however Parker
wanted to take half of the publishing
rights for the song and Parton refused
my heart I cried all night you know
because I was not going to hear Elvis
sing it so Elvis never recorded it the
Catalyst for Parker and Elvis's
relationship throughout the film starts
with their intense conversation at the
carnival Parker notices Elvis standing
alone and recognizes him as a lost
Outcast who would be easily influenced
by his management he approaches Elvis
but Elvis is suddenly called Away by his
friends to go into the house of mirrors
delaying the conversation between the
musician and manager however when Parker
first notices Elvis he notices something
else too the advertisement for the geek
posted behind his view of Elvis this
hidden detail has a deeper meaning first
a geek is known to Carnival lovers as
the most grotesque or shocking of all
the acts these performers bite the heads
off animals or even eat them alive this
slightly references 1947's nightmare
alley which was Parker's favorite film
so that's one meaning to it however it
also references the fact that Parker saw
how audiences reacted to Elvis's act and
how they couldn't control the pleasure
they felt from it but weren't sure if
they were supposed to be enjoying doing
it or rejecting it that goes for most of
the world's response to the musician
actually Parker knew Elvis could be the
music industry's geek act and took
advantage of that and his management of
the musician
one of the biggest parts of the film is
Elvis's Comeback Special which is where
you really see Elvis defy Parker to
create what he wants his audience to see
not what Parker is pressuring him to do
I don't give a damn to Colonel tanks
Elvis fans will watch the film's version
of the special and note that it is
recreated nearly perfectly by lormen
every detail of it is so precise and
Butler's performance though excellent
throughout the whole film is especially
well done here however one detail that
was particularly accurate to add is
extremely subtle but tells a huge story
in the scene when Butler's Elvis first
starts singing he reaches for the
microphone when he does this his hand
shakes slightly like he's nervous to
perform this is because the zelvis fans
will note in the original Comeback
Special Elvis hadn't performed in front
of a live audience for a long time and
was nervous this caused his hand to
shake as he was getting into the feeling
of the performance and Butler included
this sale in the film version to make it
more authentic and exact to Elvis's
Behavior at the special
one of the defining moments of Elvis's
life and in the film comes from Martin
Luther King Jr's death his assassination
deeply impacted Elvis and eventually
sparked his Rebellion against Parker's
agenda and deciding to work with Steve
Bender to create the special he wanted
to make Dr King was shot eight miles
from Graceland while I was out here
singing to Turtles however there is a
hidden detail before this while Elvis is
contemplating King Jr's death in the
scene Priscilla walks into Elvis's
trailer to find him watching Dr King's
Memorial she greets him by saying satnan
which some might take to be a pet name
or not really notice she says it at all
this was no throwaway line though
satinine is actually what Elvis used to
call his mother Gladys Presley he used
this word because of her satin smooth
skin it was more than that though
because to the two of them this word was
a form of affection Elvis and his mother
had an extremely close relationship
right up until her death it was slightly
strained by the influence of Tom Parker
but was still pure and lovely Priscilla
greeting Elvis in this way is not only a
nice way to squeeze that reference into
the film but also especially meaningful
because he's grappling with Dr King's
death and it likely brings up feelings
about his own mother's death
another small detail comes once more
with the Viva Las Vegas Hollywood movie
montage there's a scene in the top left
corner of the five panel layout where
Elvis is seen doing Priscilla's makeup
this might seem like a small piece of
romance between the two but is really a
detail that points toward a larger
circumstance between Elvis and Priscilla
most people might not know that Elvis
was very particular about Priscilla's
appearance it actually taught her how to
do her makeup and Priscilla's Memoir
Elvis and me she talked about how Elvis
created her and how she didn't really
know who she was as a person without
Elvis she wrote he taught me everything
how to dress how to walk how to apply
makeup and wear my hair how to behave
how to return love his way over the
years he became my father husband and
very nearly God
Elvis had huge control issues when it
came to Priscilla but she didn't take it
as a negative she saw it as more of a
guidance to creating who she was however
with no separation between what she
wanted and what Elvis wanted for her it
became hard for her to see herself as
her own person
one element of Elvis that fans enjoy is
the mixing of the old Elvis tracks with
the new artist's music artists like Doja
cat teamed up on the Elvis and Big Mama
Thornton hit hound dog to create a new
spin on the classics another mashup
audiences enjoyed was the Elvis song
Viva Las Vegas mixed with Britney Spears
Toxic it circulated around tick tock and
because it wasn't released on the film's
soundtrack fans begged for the cut to be
released though this song is an absolute
hit it also serves as an important
detail in the film for those wanting to
do more of a deep dive on its meaning
one of the biggest news items of 2021
and 2022 came from the movement to free
popular musician Britney Spears from her
conservatorship she was poorly managed
by her family particularly her father
and suffered a lot of abuse in the
process because this song plays while
Elvis is being manipulated in his acting
career by Parker it's clearly a
reference to how both artists were
exploited for the profits of those who
handled their affairs
you listen to me
the only thing that matters
is that that man gets up on that stage
tonight it's a small detail that people
might not immediately put together but
as bustle writes it's a way to link two
of History's iconic musicians through
some of their shared negative
experiences
[Music]